the upcoming apple glass is apple's
latest addition of another auxiliary
device to its famed apple ecosystem
these glasses will be using the
up-and-coming augmented reality
technology or ar for short ar which
should not be confused with virtual
reality or vr takes digital objects and
systems and merges them with the natural
world surrounding its user vr on the
other hand is a totally virtual world
where users can interact with digital
objects apple isn't the first one to
realize the potential of ar capable
glasses both google and microsoft have
also tried developing their own ar
glasses google's glass program was shut
down back in 2015 primarily due to poor
reception of the device by the public
users didn't like the design they
thought it was bulky and overpriced and
in the end most users admitted there was
no need for such a device at least back
then microsoft hololens on the other
hand is still under development and
could offer apple direct competition
apple glass should not be confused with
apple vr which is a totally different
product apple is also developing a mixed
reality headset but the details on that
are really scarce apple glass is totally
an augmented reality device augmented
reality itself is not something new
either remember the famous pokemon go
mobile game it also used augmented
reality to engage players and catch
pokemons but apple has a very different
goal in mind with the apple glass they
want to make it part of your daily
routine so you can swipe through your
messages as you eat your morning
breakfast without touching your phone
combined with other apple devices it
could offer an excellent creative outlet
for productivity like using apple glass
to visualize changing your house with a
new decoration style the rumor mill on
the apple glasses has been running for
months so let us take a deeper look into
what apple glasses has to offer when it
finally does come out details about the
apple glass the design philosophy with
apple glass according to apple is that
they want to bring all the information
from your phone to your face
specifically they are aiming for apple
glass to synchronize with a wearer's
iphone to display things such as texts
emails maps and games over the user's
field of vision and they want all of
this to fit into the apple ecosystem
they have already set up with other
apple devices apple also has plans to
support third-party apps and is
considering making a dedicated app store
similar to how you get apps for the
apple tv and apple watch but as we get
more into the details about the
technology behind the apple glass it
gets more exciting one such feature of
the apple glass is what can only be
described as optical sub-assembly
according to a patent filed by apple
they are planning to use apple glass as
an in-headset vision correcting system
that won't need the wearer to wear
prescription glasses beneath their apple
glass according to the patent this
optical subassembly will automatically
adjust for people with poor eyesight
gone will be the days when you'll need
to get a new prescription as devices
like apple glass will be able to change
their optical properties on the go
another patent describes that apple
glass will allow users to change the
background of the objects they see on
the fly similar to how you can change
backgrounds on video conferencing
applications like zoom or microsoft
teams and this type of feature is to be
expected from an augmented reality
wearable device the patent explains that
this will be done using a process called
chroma key where a solid color
background can be replaced with a
digital background apple glass will be
using images from its camera and
detecting color ranges to make a
composite and then digitally insert
virtual content so imagine you are
looking at a wall apple glass can start
showing you your calendar on it as you
browse through it apple glass will come
equipped with a lidar scanner on the
right hand side but up till now apple
hasn't confirmed the mounting of a
camera on the frame lidar stands for
light detection and ranging and it is a
very popular remote sensing method that
uses light to draw a picture of the
world around it this type of sensor is
most commonly used on driverless
vehicles lidar allows the sensor to map
the world around it in 3d this sensor
will be at the heart of apple glass's
ability to map the world around its user
and augment digital features via its
display another feature that is rumored
to be on the apple glass is something
that can only be described as an
immersible google street view the
difference is that unlike google street
view where you see the street on your
mobile device by using apple glass you
will be virtually transported to that
view and have a full 360 degree view of
the location information extracted from
patents also suggests that apple may use
apple glass to help users see better in
the dark this would be done using depth
sensors that could provide the user with
better spatial awareness in low light
conditions specifications in terms of
specifications most experts agree that
we can see a 52 degree field of view and
47 pixels per inch of pixel density
similar to microsoft's hololens the
apple glass is expected to use wi-fi to
connect directly to your phone since as
we mentioned it will depend on the
iphone for most of its processing the
battery life is expected to be around
three hours on a single charge but apple
will be providing some convenient
wireless charging cases to make it
feasible for users to take the apple
glass out for a long day design
according to leakers the most current
apple glass prototype looks brazenly
like a regular pair of plastic glasses
this would actually be a good thing the
less standout design the more people
will be willing to use it as an everyday
accessory and less as a gimmicky device
that they only use once to show off
apple's own marketing materials for the
apple glass suggest a clark kent look
the apple glass is designed as an
accessory to the iphone and not an
independent device similar to how
currently the apple watch functions and
since it will be equipped with various
sensors and electrical equipment you can
expect the apple glass to be a little
heavier than your conventional glasses
another exciting feature from the rumor
mill suggests that apple will be going
the modular route with swappable arms of
the apple glass frame similar to how
apple allows its apple watch users to
switch watch bands with different ones
it's refreshing to see apple giving its
users the option for more
customizability reportedly this will be
done using small magnets and divots on
the mainframe to help secure the
swappable arms concerns users do have
some concerns about the privacy with the
announcement of the apple glass imagine
recordings of what you see and do being
sent back to apple that is a scary
thought the patent file by apple does
detail a couple of fixes around the
privacy concern one fix is using a
camera module for the apple glass that
is easily removable by the user if you
choose it to do so another fix is to use
a modular key as a kill switch for the
camera a lot of laptops currently use a
similar system to turn off a
front-facing camera on their laptops
pricing price estimates about the apple
glass come from a well-reputed apple
leaker john prosser according to prosser
we can expect the price to be somewhere
around 499 dollars this is a very steep
price for a device that will be
dependent on the iphone for most of its
processing power but this is still very
reasonable compared to microsoft's
hololens which has a hefty price tag of
3 500 but if we are fair to hollow lens
it does come with all its electronics to
run an augmented reality environment
independently when can we expect a
release well the water is murky on the
release date according to a report by
bloomberg we wouldn't see the apple
glass hit the shelves until 2023 at the
earliest apple had intended to announce
that product as early as 2023 bloomberg
is basing this on information leaked
from an internal presentation shown at
apple but other industry analysts
disagree ming chi quo an analyst at tf
international securities thinks that we
might be seeing the apple glass as early
as 2022. she has been a reliable apple
expert in the past the information has
reported that apple glass has already
passed a prototype stage and has now
entered into the trial production phase
of development this means that apple
glass is very near its mass production
phase and we might be seeing apple glass
and apple stores near us soon